hey guys P here this is my QA from the
last two videos that I put out clipping
season 3 episode 5 recap and review and
the 10 things you might have missed in
episode 5 or part 5 spoiler warning if
you haven't watched up until this part
of the series then you will be spoiled
so they'll watch something else so yeah
you guys asked all the questions which
is awesome and I'm gonna do my best to
answer and if not then expand on the
question and think about what we should
be questioning I guess would be the way
to put it so I'll start out and there
are quite a few of these so I'll try to
go fast if you have you know want more
clarification just bring it up in the
comments are the prints Tammy is looking
at backwards this is a little bit tricky
and I mentioned it briefly in my 10
things you might have missed video on
the screen we see two sets of prints and
we see that one of the prints the left
ring finger seems to be mirrored this is
where it gets complicated because the
writing on that one is also mirrored
like it says 9 left ring or whatever and
it's backwards so the actual print is
not mirrored it's exactly the same it's
just a picture flipped around as best I
can tell so what does that mean no idea
the it could mean that evil coupe has a
different left ring finger and he had to
alter the records which we know he has
some technical savvy or it could mean
that that's a continuity error or a
production error that those letters
weren't supposed to be backwards because
the ones above aren't backwards or it
could mean that she turned that
particular print from one reason for
some reason and not the other ones and
yeah we don't know we know there's
something up with the prints on the
screen they're mirror images but the
lettering is backwards to make what you
will of all that Phillip Jeffries was in
the Argentine right yes that's
definitely true when I said that we
hadn't been to Argentina in the show I
was I was talking specifically about the
show Phillip Jeffries was in Gordon
Cole's office and he disappeared in fire
walk with me but he was known to be in
Argentina
he was known to disappear there so when
you watch the missing pieces he actually
sort of teleports to that to Buenos
Aires and we see him show up there and
it's a funny scene where there's a guy
standing there who crapped his pants
basically and yeah so yeah Jeffries is
associated with Argentine or anything
that's related to Argentina in the
current season should we raise Philip
Jeffries flags next question is anyone
mentioned the tags on the plate of
Dougie's car are from 2003 now this was
something that I had to go and look into
a little bit closer the license plate
here does have a no.3 which makes you
think maybe that means 2003 but I used
to live in the States and I remember
that this is something that you got
pulled over for all the time if you
weren't careful and the system works as
it's your beautiful registration each
year has a colour so that the police
officer can note it from a distance and
the number of the year is actually
pretty small and the big number is the
month and different states are different
so I look specifically for Las Vegas
Nevada state and yeah that's the way it
works the big number is 3 so this
vehicle registration expires in March of
whatever year that sticker is for so
this is actually debunked as a clue I've
never been a big fan of the theory that
you know there's a different timeline
here so I'm a little bit biased but this
part this question is easy to answer and
that is that it's not from 2003 anyone
else notice the Morley cigarettes and
yes I did and most people who are
x-files fans or where x-files fans will
remember that smoking man who was a
mysterious character in that television
series used to smoke Morley's Morley's
are a prop cigarette brand
there are several prop brands if you
think about it they use it because
there's no product placement or you know
anything like that so it's actually
showing up in a lot of things but yeah
it's cool that it you know that it's so
prominent in here because it does give a
nod whether that was in 10
not to the x-files next question what is
the newspaper article behind Norma and
the double are say if you remember she's
sitting there at the desk she's sort of
watching as Becky comes in she's doing
her work in her little booth where she
often sits and what it says is something
to the extent of double our when double
our diner wins award for best takeout
food now that doesn't necessarily mean
anything and this could have happened at
any time you see that they have the
Double R to go quite a bit on all the
stuff that's new some people quickly
jump to the assumption that this is an
alternate timeline where you know or
alternate reality I guess would be the
right way to say that like where her
mother gave them a good award but it
could be any magazine or newspaper it's
a newspaper
it could be any newspaper and it could
happen any time the last 25 years so I
don't think it's anything that we need
to pay too much attention to at this
point next question why does spooky
music when the mom wakes up well I
mentioned the music in general in my
tending to mine in this video and I
think that it is an indication that
something is going on there I mean
that's vague but the music has been
sparse so when it does show up it's
probably or reason it may take more
evidence to figure out what those
reasons are and if they're a review of
what's happening when that comes up or
whatever but I think you know it could
be a lot of things here I know that's
why I'm not really going to pick their
you know tie myself to one but think
about all the different things that are
happening there and remember that the
music is in fact probably quite
important since we don't hear very much
of it next question may be evil coop
hired the woman to kill dougie dougie
coop and maybe they communicate through
the black box
yes and yes I think when we look at the
you know definitely somebody was after
dogging me the real dougie that to his
wife's talking about she wants him to
pay back the 50 grand because somebody
is upset about that on the other hand
these people who we've seen since Cooper
started living in Dougie's life are most
likely hired by evil COO he coordinated
the switch and it's he's the one who
benefits the bet
the most from getting rid of the
original coupe so yeah I think that's
that's fair to say now we have the guys
in the black car those guys might be
related to the people who were upset
about the 50 grand and you know whatever
we don't know for sure we'll keep an eye
on it next question what is the black
box in the wooden bowl well I think it
you know we touched on it in the last
question it is the communication device
how it works not really sure who's who's
communicating to who well it seems like
evil Cooper's definitely involved maybe
Philip Jeffries because the box is in
Argentina so on and so forth we don't
really know but that evil coupe was
communicating with someone who was
either Philip Jeffries or impersonating
Phil Philip Jeffries through that
communication device he had in the
briefcase so I'm sure this is all
similar equipment that he has access to
next question how does the FBI have a
picture of Cooper in the Red Room now
this is this is related to what Tammy's
looking at and I admit that whenever I
read this the first time I looked and I
said holy crap that is the Red Room but
if you look at it a little bit closer
and kind of zoom in it is not actually
the Red Room it is the wood paneling
which someone pointed out is probably
when he was interviewed you know when he
was suspended from the FBI in the Twin
Peaks Sheriff's Department which is
completely paneled and wood paneling for
the most part so yeah that's that looks
like the Red Room it almost looks like
they might have added a red tint to the
original photograph but it is wood
paneling not a curtain behind him
next question could the guy in the bar
be Audrey son and the answer to this is
yes does that mean that he is Audrey son
the answer to that is no but yes she is
a woman of childbearing age and he is
was born since the last series happened
so it is definitely very possible and
obviously leave it at that because this
is the you know I talked about it before
and there's a lot of speculation we can
do but the question was is it possible
the answer is yes next question did
anyone else notice sonny jim blinking
backwards I'm keeping this simple as
well I did not notice a backwards blink
but yes hundreds if not thousands of
people say that they noticed that and
very possible that it happened what it
means or why it's there I have no idea I
mean obviously the the theory is that
this has something to do with the lodge
because things happen backwards in the
lodge but we don't have enough to go on
to say anything else about that next
question is evil coups hair long because
of Bob well you know that could be the
case there the question person last
question mention Leland's hair turning
white
um I think really what you know we
should keep in mind here is is that evil
coupe is a doppelganger possessed by a
spirit from the lodges so whenever they
you know get developed a brand new
character and they wanted it to be
noticeably different than clean-cut
agent Cooper so I think him having a bad
haircut and you know kind of dressing
like I don't know how to describe it but
just not just bad I guess it's all part
of highlighting the difference there is
an article or an interview out there
with Tom McLaughlin where he talks about
the creative process behind creating the
character and how he threw in his two
cents that maybe they should use black
contacts and David Lynch you know greed
and they did that so yeah I think it's
just more - I mean it's hilarious let's
not forget that he's got a really funny
look and the opening scene where he
comes out of the car is just one of the
top moments of ever in Twin Peaks I
think but yeah I don't know that Bob's
influences has something to do with this
hair or not next question is it possible
that Richard Horne is the Richard the
giant was talking about yes absolutely
the answer is yes I don't know if it is
but now there's a conspicuous - names
that we got in the very opening part of
this season and this is the first new
cast member that we have run into with
the name Richard so I think there's a
good chance might not be right but we'll
find out next question are the words
dougie coop is picking up on important I
think so yes I mean the beginning he is
picking up on everything and then in the
recent episode he's picking up on things
that are related to his own existing on
his own personality or zone personal
makeup whatever you want to say you know
he's picking up on things that are
related to
his job and things that he's starting to
remember is what the implication is so
yeah
next question it isn't dougie it is the
real Cooper returning to his old self
right yes I call him dougie Cooper for a
couple reasons one because he's living
dougie life right now and two because I
like to say the word dougie and I'm not
gonna probably stop calling him dougie
coop until that whole charade ends the
same time the real dougie is gone he's
been replaced this whole thing is a
massive scheme to keep evil coop out of
the lodge so I did a whole dougie video
some of you have seen that I'll be
touching on more of this in part two of
that but yet it is agent Cooper he's
just living somebody else's life at the
moment
next question is dougie coop looking at
the statute because it resembles harry s
truman and that is possible is this is a
this is interesting but you know a lot
of people have thoughts about the statue
I've been told as a factual piece of
evidence that it is David Bowie and
that's because it's Phil generally plays
Phillip Jeffries things like that what I
know about the statue is yes it's a prop
it doesn't belong there they brought it
in I've seen a thread where someone who
worked at the building showed a picture
without it bla bla bla and from what I
understand the actual statue was not
fashioned after David Bowie or harry s
truman it was fashioned after David
Lynch's father and yeah I mean it's
supposed to be a law enforcement person
because he is connecting with these
ideas you know as he started and put his
memory back together whatever so yeah it
could be that but it could be a lot of
things next question what happened to
the bomb it yeah as far as I know
they're still analyzing it and we can
say what happened to the investigation
around the glass box we haven't really
seen at that part of the story moved
forward in part 5 we did see Tammy but
she didn't really she didn't speak she
didn't give us any clues as to what's
going on in that so yeah I'm sure now
that he's made that call the warden will
talk to Gordon and maybe we'll find out
more about the ongoing investigation
at that point next question what
happened to Laura that's a good question
and it's one frankly that I don't think
we're supposed to know the answer to
there's no there's nothing clearer than
any evidence of that we would know where
she went
so I'll leave that at that next question
wouldn't Shelley's kid have a different
name
this um yeah she her last name is
Johnson she's married to Leo Johnson or
it was less that we knew and Becky is
her daughter
she mentions that and that her daughters
with the wrong guy and so on and so
forth and we know that she's with
Stephen they both have the same last
name they're probably married next
question what will happen if Cooper has
some cherry pie this is in relation to
the coffee and yeah maybe it could be
that quirky that that's the missing
ingredient here for him waking up
completely but I kind of hope not we'll
see what happens but yeah it's a funny
question either way next question what
if the key is the key to the whole thing
and then this is talking about maybe the
you know maybe the Great Northern
somewhat Native American related I think
two things here I think Hawk is the most
overlooked thing in the whole transfer
from the lodge scenario which I hope to
touch on more soon and the other thing
is yes I think the key is the whole
thing but to the story shifting focus
back to Twin Peaks
we know that keys on route we know it
arrives things will fall into place I
don't know how fast but one way or
another this is going to lead to the
idea of where agent Cooper is currently
at and I'm sure this is going to involve
the Twin Peaks Sheriff's Department and
most likely the FBI so yeah I think the
key is super important and I don't know
I mean I think the hawk stuff is related
to his Nez Perce heritage not just being
an Indian but you will find out next
what is the secret history of Twin Peaks
and that is a good question if you don't
know it's a novel it's not necessarily a
book that is in a traditional book it's
put together as a dossier and I can't
spoil a speech so I won't go into the
details of that too much but mark frost
the co-creator wrote it it came out just
before season three or you know a few
months before and super interesting
there's a link in my description
and where you can learn more about that
it is really get all the descriptions of
my videos to that and basically it's a
book that fills in some of the blanks
and then there's another one scheduled
for after season three concludes called
the final dossier that's supposed to
fill in more so go through the link if
you want or just Google secret history
and you can find out more about that and
the last question for the day is it
really Twin Peaks anymore so yeah I
think in my opinion it is I think it's
exactly what it should be as far as
where I mean it's been 25 years and the
reality is the people in that town in
that community have lived their lives
for that period of time now is the Twin
Peaks in the sense that everything is
exactly the same no but I don't think it
should be in I think it's really
interesting that this episode seemed to
put people on both sides really
polarizing in a way so like episode 3
was or part 3 was in that some people
loved it and some people hated it I
think you know my thinking is is that
the creators the showrunners you know
they would probably like that because
you know they're trying to make
something based off work that they did
quite a while ago and they're trying to
make it fresh and interesting and I
think that you know it's not important
that every episode is to everyone's
liking I mean you can't you know you
can't advocate you know being creative
you can't expect to connect with
everybody or you know the old saying you
can't please all the people all the time
and I think you know the the basic
premise of why Twin Peaks became so
popular especially with the general
public was the mystery around you know
the way that it presented mystery and it
presented all these characters and it
made you want to try to figure out what
was going on I think this is the same
thing it might be on steroids at this
point because we're looking at a longer
run that is
you know more tightly controlled by the
two creative forces behind it but yeah I
think it's great I think it's just
evolved we're all 25 years older and
let's see what happens man I'm
optimistic you know we will have to see
what goes on but I think it is I think
it's true to the process to the
experience of the first one we're just
at a different time and this is a
different installment all right thanks
everything thanks so much for all the
questions and interaction it's a lot of
fun I enjoy the feedback both positive
and you know things that I can improve
on I'll do my best to do that all the
time got a couple things playing for the
weekend and then we get part six so yeah
please subscribe to the channel like the
video check through the playlist there's
a lot of different ones that I've been
putting out and thanks for watching I'll
talk to you soon